the US and its allies are ganging up on
Russia over the poisoning of a former
spy the Kremlin is promising retaliation
tonight senior foreign affairs
correspondent amy kellogg is once again
in moscow the UK and its allies the u.s.
germany and france presented a united
front a statement of solidarity saying
they all agree with britain's assessment
that russia was responsible for the
attack on a Russian double agent and his
daughter it said in part quote this use
of a military-grade nerve agent of a
type developed by Russia constitutes the
first offensive use of a nerve agent in
Europe since the Second World War adding
its quote an assault on UK sovereignty
and a breach of international law a day
after announcing punitive measures
against Russia British Prime Minister
Theresa May visited the cathedral city
of Salisbury where Sergei skeeball and
his daughter Yulia were mysteriously
poisoned on March 4th Russia saying it
will soon expel British diplomats in
response to Britain's decision to kick
out 23 Russians continues to deny it had
anything to do with the poisoning and
continues to request a sample of the
agent Russian officials have said that
the British Prime Minister weakened by
troubles negotiating the brexit deal is
simply trying to build strength by
lashing out at Russia but that this can
all be set straight we are ready to
return into partnership with the
European Union when our European
neighbors lose interest in following
American Russia phobic tendencies
Britain finds Russia's attitude
untenable
it is absolutely atrocious troche as'
and outrageous what Russia did in
Salisbury we have responded to that
frankly Russia should go away it should
shut up his comments may fuel the
Russians argument that Britain is
provoking them
Brett in fact the Russian Ministry of
Defense felt compelled to answer that
last comment tonight issuing a statement
decrying the British defense Secretary's
what they called coarse language
something that they said perfectly
characterizes his quote intellectual
impotence in the meantime no one here
expects that this furthering sense of
siege in Russia now is going to have any
negative impact on President Vladimir
Putin's popularity Brett Amy Kellogg
live in Moscow early Friday morning Amy
thank you